jusque là on a vu deux théories
mathématiques dans l'épisode 13 on a
parlé de l'arithmétique de p and o et
dans l'épisode 19
on a mentionné la théorie z fc on a
aussi parlé de l'inclusion de
l'exclusion de l'action du choix voire
de l'hypothèse du continu toutes ses
mathématiques sont dit standard mais à
force de baigner dans ce qui est
standard on en vient à oublier tout le
champ des possibles aujourd'hui je vous
propose d'aller plus loin et de
découvrir si mathématiques alternative
théorie alternatifs 1
l'arithmétique de robinson comment sont
légers l'arithmétique de robinson est ce
que l'on obtient lorsque l'on part de
l'arithmétique de pernod et que l'on
enlève le schéma d'actium de récurrence
celui qui se décomposait en une infinité
d'actium on obtient alors une théorie
axiomatique avec un nombre fini taxes y
sommes ce qui peut paraître rassurant
et bien non certes l'arithmétique de
robinson est capable de prouver que un
plus un égale à 2 ou que 39 n'est pas un
nombre premier cependant l'arithmétique
de robinson est incapable de prouver
quoi que ce soit de général elle est
incapable de prouver par exemple qu'il
existe un nombre infini de nombreux
premiers ou que n + m est toujours
légale am plus haine pour tout entier m
et n l'arithmétique de robinson et donc
incomplète puisque la commune activités
de l'addition est un problème
indécidable
théorie alternative 2 l'arithmétique de
pressburger pour l'instant on n'a vu que
des théories mathématiques auxquelles le
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel
s'appliquait pourtant il en fait très
simple de créer une théorie dans
laquelle il n'y a pas de vérité
mystérieusement non démontrable pour
cela il suffit de retirer le symbole de
la multiplication certes il reste
possible d'exprimer des trucs qui
ressemble à démultiplication par une
constante par exemple 3 x x peut être
réécrit comme étant x 15 x + x
cependant il devient impossible de
montrer par exemple que la
multiplication et commutative parce
qu'il est impossible d'écrire x x y ou x
et y sont tous les deux des variables en
fait l'arithmétique sans le symbole de
la multiplication que l'on appelle
l'arithmétique de près ce burger et
décide à bhl est complète ici elle est
complète c'est parce que sont engagés à
limiter en particulier elle est
incapable de formuler un théorème qui
exprimerait la commune activités de
multiplication ces restreignant mais ça
a du bon en particulier le second
théorème d'incomplétude de gödel celui
qui dit une théorie ne peut pas prouver
sa propre cohérence ne s'applique
désormais plus en effet il s'agit en
fait d'un théorème que d'affirmer que
l'arithmétique pressburger n'a aucun
paradoxe
mieux encore pressburger démontra en
1929 qu'il existait une méthode
systématique un algorithme qui étant
donné n'importe quel théorème finira
toujours en temps finit par trouver une
preuve de ce théorème ou de son inverse
tout théorème de l'arithmétique de près
ce burger est donc vrai ou faux et un
ordinateur sera toujours capable de
déterminer s'il est l'un ou l'autre on
dit que l'arithmétique de près ce burger
et décide à bhl de la même façon
l'arithmétique de ce col m qui lui exclu
le symbole de l'addition est une théorie
mathématique décide à bhl mieux encore
des théories modernes sont capables de
parler à la fois de la soustraction et
de la division tout en restant décide à
bhl c'est mathématique alternatives ont
le bon goût d'échapper au théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel
mais elles ont le défaut d'être trop
limité pour faire tout ce que l'on
aimerait pouvoir faire avec des nombres
comme parler à la fois de la vision et
de la multiplication
théorie alternative 3 la géométrie de
tarse qui dit souvent dans la géométrie
d'euclide quelle est la première théorie
mathématique axiomatique cependant les
actions de la théorie d'euclide sont en
fait très floues selon les standards de
la logique formelle moderne en 1959
alfred tarski dont on a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 15 chercha à formaliser la
géométrie d'euclide ce qui lui convient
à ce que je vais appeler la géométrie de
tarse qui dans cette géométrie de tarse
qui les objets sont en fait les points
de l'espace mathématiques et il existe
trois relations possibles entre les
points de la géométrie de tard ce qu'est
la première est celle présente ce dont
toutes les théories formelle à savoir le
symbole de l'égalité en particulier
selon les règles de la logique classique
on sait que si deux points sont égaux
alors toute propriété vrai pour l'un va
être vrai pour l'autre la seconde
relation relie trois objets de la
théorie à b et c et elle dit que à b et
c sont alignés dans cet ordre en
particulier b se trouve entre a et c il
est ensuite tout plein d'action autour
de cette relation d'alignement par
exemple si on a à b à c lire ci paie et
entra et a alors à était gay à la baie
un autre actionne intéressant et
n'actionne de continuité ou plutôt le
schéma d'actium de continuité en gros ce
qu'il dit c'est que si on a un ensemble
de points qui se trouvent toujours d'un
même côté par rapport à un autre
ensemble de points et que tous ces
points sont toujours aligné alors il
existe un point entre les deux ensembles
et ça pour ceux qui ont suivi l'épisode
hardcore ça ressemble pas mal à la coupe
de 2,2 kind la troisième relation est
une relation entre quatre objets de la
théorie de tarse qui a b et c d et elle
dit en gros que la distance
ab est égale à la distance scellés et
cette égalité il annote un petit peu
différemment avec un autre symbole
d'égalité puisque ce n'est pas la même
égalité que l'égalité entre des points
de la théorie de tard ce qui là encore
un axiome qui permet d'utiliser cette
relation pour prouver l'égalité entre
des points en particulier si on aa
bettega la ccl ça veut dire que la
distance entre a et b et la même contre
ses essais et ça ça implique que a est
égal à b jusque là nos actions
permettent de faire de jeu
mais trimer cette géométrie n'est pas
forcément aux clients viennent pour la
rendre plus diène il nous faut rajouter
l'équivalent du cinquième axiome
d'euclide dont on a parlé dans cet
épisode alors il ya beaucoup de
formulation équivalente du cinquième
axiome d'euclide l'une d'elles consiste
à dire que le théorème des milieux et
vérifier autrement dit si je prends
n'importe quel triangle abaissée si
j'appelle x et y les milieux deco tu es
ab est assez alors xy va avoir une
longueur qui est la moitié de la
distance baissé et ça dans le formalisme
de la géométrie de tarse lit ça nous
donne cette formule logique
bref la géométrie de tard ce qui permet
donc de faire de la géométrie
euclidienne mais les actions qu'on a vu
jusque là ne précise pas la dimension de
l'espace aux clients en fait avec les
actions qu'on l'avait vu jusque là on
pourrait très bien faire d'ajoie méfiant
dimensions 1 et ainsi définir des
espèces de nombres réels ou de la
géométrie en dimensions 196 1883 pour
préciser la dimension de la géométrie de
tarse qu'il nous faut rajouter deux
axiomes le premier des axiomes nous dit
que la dimension de l'espace va être au
moins égal à 2 est le deuxième
actionnaire dit qu'il va être au plus
égale à 2 et la magie magie on obtient
une théorie axiomatique du premier ordre
qui permet de formaliser la géométrie
d'euclide et qui est taissy d'érable
autrement dit tout et orane de la
géométrie de tard ce qui est vrai ou
faux et il existe un algorithme qui sera
toujours capable de déterminer s'il est
l'un ou l'autre
théorie alternative 4 le corps réel clos
ici on court circuiter l'arithmétique de
paix à nos pourparlers des nombres réels
ce pari fou de tard ce qui est encore
lui permit de développer la théorie
décors réels clos pour se faire tard ce
qui se reposait sur les axiomes de la
théorie des corps et de la relation
d'ordre sur l'existence des racines
carrées et sur l'existence de solutions
aux équations polynomiale 2° un père si
on ne se restreint alors à des formules
qui n'utilisent que la multiplication
l'addition la soustraction le symbole
égal ou le symbole supérieur ou égal et
si on s'interdit de manipuler des
ensemble de nombres alors la théorie
décors réels clos ordonné est une
théorie des six tables car ce qu'il
réussit en particulier a développé un
algorithme est capable de décider si un
théorème de la théorie décors réels clos
est vrai ou faux le seul problème c'est
que cet algorithme est un peu mes gars
super lent et en donner une formule de
longueur elle il est impossible de dire
que cette algue auquel va prendre moins
de temps que deux ^ ^ ^ ^ et ainsi de
suite avec un âne à la fin le temps de
calcul est plus grand que n'importe quel
tour d'exposants ciel autre bizarrerie
la théorie de terre ce qui est incapable
de parler des expos nantiat sion est ce
que la théorie reste des sea dogs
lorsque l'on prend en compte les
exponentielle on ne sait pas il s'agit
là de l'un des nombreux problèmes
ouverts de la recherche sur les
fondations mathématiques
théorie alternative 5 l'arithmétique
oméga incohérente
pour finir on va faire un truc super
médias bizarre on va partir de
l'arithmétique de pme comme on l'a vu
dans l'épisode 18 goodell a réussi à
traduire la validité des preuves de
l'arithmétique de p and o dans le
langage de l'arithmétique de pn aussi
bien que dire que des mots prouve
théorème revient à dire qu'il existe une
formule qui relie les codes numériques
de démos et de terrain on a aussi vu
qu'il était possible de construire un
théorème que je vais appeler j'ai pour
google qui dit que j'ai n'a pas de
preuves et on avait vu que si
l'arithmétique de p and o et est
consistante
alors j'ai devait forcément être vrai
ainsi la consistance de l'arithmétique
de p and o implique
g mais si on est maintenant capable de
formaliser cette implication dans
l'arithmétique dopé anneaux et si on est
capable de prouver la consistance de
l'arithmétique de p and o alors on
pourra en déduire une preuve que j'ai
est vrai or j'ai dit que faisait n'a pas
de preuve
donc on aurait un paradoxe en fait c'est
précisément ça le second théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel si on a une
preuve de la consistance de
l'arithmétique de p and o alors on est
capable de prouver le théorème g avec
cette preuve de la consistance
arithmétique de p and o et du coup on
obtient un paradoxe
la preuve de la consistance de
l'arithmétique de p and o un pic son
inconsistance
mieux encore on a vu que la preuve de
consistance un piquet l'inconsistance de
la théorie mais si je prends maintenant
la contra poser de cela je sais que la
consistance de la théorie implique
l'absence de preuve de consistance
écrivant maintenant tout cela dans le
langage de l'arithmétique de p and o la
preuve de la consistance revient à dire
que pour toute tentative de preuves
n il est faux de dire que n prouve
quelque chose d'incohérent comme par
exemple un égal 0 si je prends
maintenant la négation de cela je vois
que l'absence de preuves d'inconsistance
revient à dire qu'il est faux de dire
que pour tout n n ne prouve pas un égal
et ça d'après les règles de la logique
c'est équivalent à dire qu'il existe un
n tels que n est une démonstration de un
égal zéro et ça ça veut dire que je peux
rajouter à l'arithmétique de p and o un
axiome qui dit qu'il existe une preuve
de l'inconsistance de la théorie et si
l'arithmétique de pernod était
consistante alors arithmétique de paix à
nos plus existence de preuves
d'inconsistance reste une théorie
consistant alors il faut savoir que la
quasi-totalité des mathématiciens crois
que l'arithmétique de p and o est vrai
et ça ça veut dire qu'ils seront forcés
de croire que cette arithmétique de
pernod plus cet axiome qui postulent
l'existence d'une preuve d'inconsistance
reste consistante
autrement dit la quasi-totalité des
mathématiciens crois qu'il existe des
théories qui affirme leur inconsistance
mais qui sont en fait consistante
on dit que la théorie que l'on vient de
construire et oméga inconsistante et
bien l'existence de théories oméga
consistante et consistante
c'est l'un des pires paradoxe apparent
de l'histoire de la logique et la raison
pour laquelle une théorie consistante
pourrait malgré tout être oméga
consistante réside sans doute dans
l'interprétation du symbole il existe en
logique classique le symbole il existe
signifie qu' il existe mais ne signifie
pas que l'on peut effectivement accès
les construire l'objet dont on a prouvé
l'existence
donc si on regarde de plus près l'axiome
qui postulent l'existence d'une
inconsistance
mais on voit que cet axiome nous dit
juste qu'il existe cet objet cette prof
d'inconsistance mais nous dit pas
comment la construire et bien finalement
le fait que cette action ne nous disent
pas comment construire la preuve
d'inconsistance fait qu' on ne pourra
peut-être jamais construire une preuve
d'un consistance et c'est peut-être ça
qui rendra la théorie malgré tout
consistante
enfin ce que je raconte là est vraiment
what the fuck et google lui-même a
vraiment essayé de lutter contre
l'existence de théories oméga
inconsistante
mais peut-être que la raison de cette
bizarrerie résidait tout simplement dans
le fait que le symbole il existe ne doit
pas se lire il existe ou du moins qui ne
correspond pas du tout à notre intuition
de ce qu'ils devraient vraiment signifié
et s'il ya un tel décalage entre la
logique formelle et notre intuition
c'est peut-être parce qu'il ya un truc à
rejeter dans la logique classique
formelle spoiler alert je suis de ceux
qui pensent qu'il est un truc car
aujourd'hui dans la logique classique
forme
la dernière fois on a parlé des
mathématiques modernes de bourbaki et
créé 2 97 comme beaucoup parmi vous se
plaignent du
de la chute du niveau des programmes
scolaires alors encore une fois il y
aurait beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
dire et je n'ai pas envie de dire de
bêtises la ou deux trucs mal dit en
quelques minutes ou qui seront mal mais
l'interpréter mais je vais quand même
donné un petit thé ldr endroit je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de contenu
aujourd'hui dans les programmes
scolaires et qu'il faudrait plus à l'est
dans la profondeur et la conséquence
néfaste de l'immensité du programme
scolaire du contenu du problème scolaire
et le fait que du coup les élèves se
contentent peuvent se contenter pour
tous qu'elle se contente d'apprendre un
peu mécaniquement et parker et ça c'est
pas du tout intéressant c'est pas du
tout souhaitable c'est pas du tout
souhaité par les mathématiciens que je
connais et je pense que c'est bien que
dans les programmes scolaires il est
beaucoup plus d'invitation à
l'exploration et tout ça je sais que
c'est très difficile notamment vis-à-vis
de l'examination puisque aujourd'hui
l'école est quand même sens et
sélectionné en grande partie et que
malheureusement sélectionne beaucoup sur
les maths et que du coup on va faire des
examens où il ya des réponses aura une
réponse fausse et qu'il n'y a pas trop
de place du coup pour l'exploration et
des réponses plus sophistiqués difficile
à corriger tout ça bref c'est un énorme
énorme problème mais le tld rc que je
pense qu'il faut moins de contenu moins
de choses que les gens doivent savoir
est beaucoup plus une invitation à la
réflexion à l'exploration et un système
de notation qui correspond beaucoup plus
à la capacité des étudiants à se poser
des questions à proposer des idées à
proposer des pistes de réflexion et puis
à écrire de même une preuve complète
claire peut être un autre truc auquel
sur lesquels
on insiste un peu plus à l'école c'est
la clarification des idées je pense
qu'un des gros objectifs de l'école et
de l'enseignement mathématiques ça doit
être une aide à clarifier les idées
parce que la plupart des idées qui sont
dans le monde soit en fait complètement
pas claires et que c'est un énorme
problème souvent dans les débats
politiques et tout ça est tellement de
choses sont mal définies sont pas
claires et tout du coup fourré vraiment
favoriser et encourager autant que
possible un effort de clarté de la part
des élèves c'est ce que je pense et
certaines des aides
enfin il y aura beaucoup beaucoup plus à
dire sur ce sujet kamaz ait des aides
fait remarquer que dans l'épisode
précédent j'ai défini l'addition à
partir de l'addition et c'est tout à
fait vrai c'était une vidéo de
vulgarisation et je suis pas rentrer
dans les détails du formalisme des
déchets qui sont très galère mais j'ai
pris le temps de parler vachement
rigoureusement de la théoriser d'accès
dans l'épisode hardcore que je vous
invite à aller voir si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur la vraie logique
formelle sur laquelle reposent toutes
les fondations mathématiques ou en tout
cas les mathématiques standard enfin il
ya un excellent commentaire de max max
qui parle d'une méthode assez générale
pour prouver l'indécidabilité de
théorèmes dans une théorie est en effet
j'aurais du site et ça c'est un
excellent commentaire de mr max max que
je vous invite à lire m'être posé à lire
alors très rapidement ce dont ils passés
de la théorie des modèles que j'ai un
peu mentionné à gauche à droite depuis
le début de cette série sur l'infini en
gros la théorie des modèles ça consiste
à se poser la question de ce qui existe
une instance concrètes qui satisfait les
axiomes d'une théorie mathématique est
donc un exemple très basique de
modèle et de théorique c'est la théorie
des groupes que la théorie des groupes
là nous dit que un groupe c'est un
ensemble d'objets avec une opération
espèce de multiplication qui lisent les
éléments du groupe et il ya certes un
axiome que doivent satisfaire cette
relation cette opération entre les
éléments du groupe donc la théorie des
deux groupes on peut voir ça comme une
théorie mathématique axiomatique avec
ses actions donc avec cette théorie on
peut former analysé de nouveautés homme
qui s'exprime uniquement dans le langage
de la théorie par exemple on peut se
demander c'est pour toutes xe pour tout
y x y relate cho est égal à y x est ce
que l'opération de du groupe de la
théorie des coupes toujours commutatif
alors là si on y va un petit peu vite
envie de dire non puisqu'il existe des
groupes week-end il faut mais en fait la
théorie axiomatique des koopas nous
demande de prouver la communauté
ativités ou linverse dragons comme
intuitivité la non commutative it et à
partir uniquement des axiomes de la
théorie des groupes et là on se rend
compte qu'en fait que c'est impossible
que c'est un problème indécidable ou ne
peut pas partir les axiomes de la
théorie des groupes et on déduire une
preuve de communes ativités ou une
preuve de la non comme une activité et
pour montrer qu en fait n'existe pas de
telles preuves que c'est un problème
indécidable ce qu'on peut faire c'est
construire des groupes concret donc par
exemple on peut construire le groupe a
de l'élément - et plus sain et la
notification classique
vous pouvez vérifier que cette tension
de 6 x y sont à chaque fois ou bien
moins un ou bien plus sain et ben
j'aurais tous les actions qui sont
toujours vérifier alain verte on peut
considérer un autre groupe par exemple
le groupe des permutations à trois
éléments
troisièmement vous regardez toutes les
façons de les mélanger chaque mélange
doit être un élément du groupe
et bien pour le groupe des permutations
et troisièmement on peut voir que
la commune activité est fausse du coup
on a deux groupes explicite de modèles
de la théorie des groupes dans lesquels
la commune activité est vrai dans l'ain
est fausse dans l'autre et lorsqu'on a
de tels modèles qui satisfont les
axiomes de la théorie mais qui donne
de conclusion différente par rapport à
certains théorème on sait que ce
théorème est un théorème indécidable
dans la théorie axiomatique initial est
donc cette façon de raisonner
c'est exactement ce qui a été utilisé
par paul cohen pour montrer par exemple
l'indécidabilité de l'hypothèse du
continu dans ces décès j'espère que vous
avez aimé cet épisode la prochaine fois
on parlera de l'un des concepts les plus
merveilleux des mathématiques savoir le
concept disons morphisme j'en profite
aussi pour vous dire que je serai au
festival vidéo sens au carrefour du
numérique
le week-end du 21-22 janvier donc à la
cité des sciences je vous ai mis un rien
dans la description vers l'inscription
pour l'événement ne sait pas s'il sera
complet d'ici là tout cas je vous invite
à sauter vraiment su réveiller parce que
je pense que ça va partir at il dit
si vous avez aimé cet épisode penser le
leak et à le commenter à le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes merci aussi
peur pour leurs dons et j'espère que je
verrai la prochaine fois dubai world
music machine
mais jobs qu'on s'y prenne six belles
choses avec universal elle tue le
philosophe mouvement
il